let me ask you about alien abductions
we've all heard about it I was in my you
know I got sucked up into a saucer or or
whatever like like
it we know UFOs exist do we know with
equal certainty the these stories of
people being abducted by aliens are also
true
I mean people that that claim that if
you hear the the Travis Walton is very
famous story Travis Walton story of
abduction he went missing for a number
of days people Fire in the Sky yeah Fire
in the Sky is's a great movie you people
were going to be put in jail they would
passed polygraphs on that abduction
story so that one carries weight and if
one is true you know who am I to say
others are not I'm sure there's a lot of
[__] ones but is that basic
phenomenon real I think we're just just
learning to form an alphabet here to
have a conversation about
UFOs that's down the road in my eyes is
we have to get to consensus reality on
actual reality if UFOs are real and we
accept that now it's a different era
than it was 10 years ago if we are all
there now right then we need to go into
the next phase of that which is do we
have craft from them either crashed or
gifted have we been exploiting them what
have we
learned then the hard questions will
come cuz if our government admits all
that people going to ask so can can you
just get swooped up you know can that
happen why now a lot of people that have
had what you call abductions there's
also a lot of people that just have what
you call contact right okay so there's a
famous case um aerial school and uh two
of the the women now that were children
at the time lisel and Salma are friends
of mine I've talked with them
extensively about it they were kid kids
and this craft or craft multiple come
down drop into this aerial school well
documented 60 90 kids I don't know bunch
of kids saw it drew pictures of it John
Mack from Harvard who was head of U
Psychiatry or something or was this in
another country in Africa yeah I think
it was South Africa if I get it right
AAL school and um he went down there and
with the BBC and he interviewed all
these kids you know head of of Harvard
in this field it was a coup that he'
take this seriously this abduction thing
so he took it seriously he's smarter
than me he was smarter than me you know
he's passed away but I'd have to imagine
that there's where there's smoke there's
fire there's got to be something to it
it's not my field I'm a more like nuts
and bullets like push on the government
get some answers kind of guy but I would
say there there's got to be something to
it and and and that's mind-boggling
because these kids they weren't abducted
but what happened was the craft land and
there's this being small you can imagine
like an alien looking being and its eyes
this is what every witness said and
especially my two friends they were like
I was like what's the best word for this
and they're like
mesmerized what do you mean it was like
as if all the sound went away and I was
being shown imagery in my mind of like
how we're [__] up the Earth which is
a very common thing people say when they
have these Close Encounters it's like a
movie they're playing in their head and
they said it was like trans fixed and
then as soon as I broke my gaze all of
that went away it lost the control over
me was communicating telepathically you
hear that all the time now I've never
had that experience Al sometimes I think
my wife is an alien hybrid kind of spy
From Another Dimension and she does mind
control me so maybe it's like that but
whatever it is there's got to be
something to it steo I don't know man
there's got to be something to it I just
think it's interesting that we've come
so far in the one area but these
situations of contact we just
like yeah well nobody owns the
UFO like it's very Democratic you know
it's like right it's like it happens to
everybody in every field and I think
once you like see one or something
you're like okay I know that shit's real
you get kind of like the bug right for
some people
um I don't know nobody owns this thing I
think that there is contact it appears
with individuals more than even
governments and if that's the case I
don't know what's going on um one
question in the context of
interdimensional and these different
ideas that maybe we can't proceed them
in this Dimension and they're in another
dimension um I've known multiple people
who have had encounters with other
species um uaps whatever you want to
refer to them as through the dream state
and I wanted to ask you about for one
also to confirm these people also were
spoken through T telepathically so they
didn't speak but they were able to
communicate and the same message in one
of the instances was spreading the same
message of hey you guys are damaging
this entire planet and that sends a
ripple effect you know one thing gets
blown up it changes and and has a
Ricochet effect onto the next things
around it but I wanted to ask you about
the dream state and if you've heard many
instances where people are reached
through the dream state and if you think
that maybe they're not physically
visible or you know maybe they're not
unveiling themselves in this Dimension
by choice or maybe they don't even have
the skills and if it's in the dream St
and if you think not to get too many
questions at once but maybe that's a
time where we're not our guards down in
the dream state maybe they're easier to
reach out to us where it's not as we're
not going to have a crazy freak out or
if they can even maybe reach us in some
cases in this Dimension yeah I mean your
gas is is as good as mine unfortunately
when it comes to that so I have made
myself um available to hear everybody's
account now what I can do with that if
it's actionable for me if it's something
that is you know profoundly personal I
like to hear it because I feel like
censoring information before it comes to
me so I'm very open to hearing I've
heard every story you can imagine when
it comes to abductions when it comes to
close encounters when it's military
personnel when it's whistle like I've
heard it all man the the thing is or
maybe I haven't let's let's see what I
hear next right nothing will shock me
but there are things that continue to
repeat amongst people that don't know
each other
and that's where it gets really kind of
Haunting to me not even in the typical
UFO Zeitgeist just little details that
continuously be are repeated and I asked
to record those conversations I can use
like you know AI word search and I can
find now you know a decade of interviews
where people are repeating things and
they don't know each other and it's not
popular stuff just little things um so I
don't know if it's dream state some
people say on like DMT they can see some
alens I didn't I mean I don't know but
you don't need to be asleep or high to
see this UFO thing I think you just need
to look up but that may be where you're
in between states that could be a place
where they can reach you I'm with you
bro yeah I had a friend who was really
big into DMT and he had an instance
where cuz a lot of people they meet
entities it might not be referred to as
aliens but they meet other beings which
I've heard it you know there's some
something that I think is interesting we
could talk about too is just the idea of
aliens vers ghost versus Angels you know
people are talking about entities not
even necessarily knowing what they are
but that energy that maybe is in an in
between realm I've experimented with DMT
a lot of times never experienced beings
but it's a very common thing but um this
person was actually being he said it was
what he interpreted as an alien actually
like doing um some form of surgery he
said it tickled them though and he
didn't feel threatened or anything he
was just laughing by it but it wasn't
like he felt like he was abducted did
but he felt like he was there were
someone there was working on him that's
like another conversation but heard that
a lot I think that when you talk about
being contacted in a dream state like
actual like dreaming I think that that
suggestion lends more credibility to
Dreaming than it really deserves not
that we don't dream but just my
experience of dreaming is just all such
absurd nonsense that just doesn't you
know well to answer that one thing CU I
know someone
who
his wife doesn't believe in aliens and
he does and he said that in the instance
where the time he met them and they came
to visit him after he had disclosed a
bunch of information his wife basically
was saying hey I had a dream last night
where a bunch of alien these tall gray
aliens came to the house and he didn't
perceive it as a Dream from what I
understand but she did and so I just
think that's interesting because it's
not like oh I had a dream it's like two
people had the same dream right have you
guys ever had like a dream or like some
information that you just knew that you
had no conventional way of knowing it
and it ended up being
true
probably
um you mean like intuition I I don't
know what I mean just um just that if if
if we have received information in some
way that we didn't know how there's no
logical way that we know like no one
told you it or wrote it down it wasn't
even in the air then somehow there's
information that gets into us from
somewhere else it's like aund monkeys
Theory sure that old yeah that book I I
believe in that I don't know that I've
had personal experience
um my my dad and my uh former stepmom
went to a uh medium like a psychic the
psychic
said um that the spirit of um my dad's
first wife which is my mother is
restless because her ashes have not been
scattered who like they and and and
literally my mom had been passed was
cremated um my sister had the this urn
with the ashes uh like literally on on
the top shelf inside her closet and and
we didn't you know just hadn't thought
of like of something anything to do with
it and like that that's pretty pretty
majorly specific that like the the my
mom's Spirit like uh like what needed to
be set free like you you need to do the
ashes so it's a good example right so
here here's my point now we could argue
okay if you got ashes and you know this
5050 chance he scattered them or not but
but it's still no nobody nobody she's
even created yeah I me so here's the
deal whether we that is something we'll
have to choose to have to believe now
that information can kind of go into a
human consciousness without traditional
meaning we don't know yet how it works
it appears the UFO thing and information
to most people that experience that it's
a non-traditional kind of communication
so there's just so much we don't know we
we've been learning over and over for
the decades that that Consciousness does
play a role with physical matter right
that's something that we've all kind of
been accustomed to saying now but how
[__] weird is that that like there's
a state of matter can be altered by The
Observer if there's Consciousness
observing it this goes back to the
double slit experiment everybody knows
this right but have we absorbed this
like this is [__] crazy this means
that Consciousness somehow dictates the
result of physical reality so the world
is so
biocentrism what is that tell me that
this is the the the idea
that the that Consciousness like creates
the universe not like uh the other way
around the brain yeah right so well look
dude I I don't know any of these answers
but but what it is dawn on me that we
are so what's the word like hubristic
like we're just so our hubris gets in
the way so we're like well that can't be
true because and you look like a fool if
you talk about that so
know look
maning our own in the foot with that
kind of thing everything should be on
the table as we kind of look into this
new realm right so this idea that UFOs
and like some people I remember Carl
Young wrote this book about how he
thought UFOs were a physical
manifestation of human consciousness now
talk about hubis first of all that's
[__] crazy I think he changed his M
later but whatever this is this UFO
thing there seems to be a phys physical
mechanical aspect to it that really
excites our military for reverse
engineering but there also seems to be
this other realm when it comes to the
UFO experience that has more to do with
human interact we're the common
denominator but Consciousness right
that's when you get into all the weird
[__] that is that's associated with UFOs
so often times when someone says I had a
close encounter that's the only part
they feel comfortable telling you but
there's like weirder [__] that happen
that they don't freely admit anybody can
say I saw UFO now you could say that
people are not going to shame you but
you start saying other stuff it just
gets a little weird I had h a lot of of
um experiences with psychosis from when
I was active in drug addiction and I I
um you know I've been cleaning sober for
15 years now and still like abs and and
at no point since I had these
experiences have I ever wavered in that
like all of the stuff that I experienced
was totally real and and by totally real
I I think to to describe
it um I arrived at the
conclusion that by piling these
substances into my body all these
chemicals and that that that I was
effectively
eroding what I would call the barriers
between like our sort of you know 3D
compartment and you know and like and
other which is a very dangerous thing to
do uh through like uh ingestion of
substances
because by eroding the barriers you open
yourself up to
all forms of of energies low high so so
you well I was welcoming in like Angels
and Demons is how I would refer to it
like super low so it's it's a dangerous
kind of a scary thing psychosis because
you're inviting in like all this
lowlevel frequency like demon [__] and
um but also it iname angels and like
they were like there was uh just a lot
of of fascinating experiences I had I
would classify it as demons that I
called uh trickster Spirits cuz they
would just entertain the [__] out of me
like just like my whole apartment would
turn into this crazy light show and like
everything was you know like like uh how
long would this go on for it like it
would like I would have episodes that
would last for like you know a number of
hours I would be in this I would be in
this like you know and different things
would happen for moments you know like
there was this uh skateboard that I had
drilled to the wall and to the
skateboard I had drilled the base of a
of an a glob GL like an atlet like a you
know globe that would sit on a desk so
it was protruding sideways out of the
the wall over the door and I sat there
and I watched my own face like like as
if the globe was like it was like a the
liquid Terminator my own face came
pushing through this globe and and and
it was like I I watched it and then the
the the globe itself with my face
protruding out of it just started like
it was like headbanging like you know
and I remember thinking like dude this
is so crazy like and like this this
can't be real I'm like I'm still seeing
it like you know I had that moment to be
like this can't be real it's still there
like and then like another beat like and
it's still happening like this is insane
what do you think that is that's a
different dimension or what I mean my
take on it was that it was just heavy
demon stuff because like when like when
the chair that I was in just erupted
into Flame and I was just like wow I'm
sitting in a chair that's completely on
fire I'm totally engulfed in flames but
it does it's not hurting me it's just
like wow cool you know like I'm just
sitting in this huge fire you got your
money's worth on the drugs yeah like
like stoked there were all like the
curtains opening and closing while these
lights are going off and like just all
these different like crazy experiences I
had and and my only response to it all
was just to try to keep shoveling more
drug into my body to keep these things
happening and so that's like n that's
scary demon [__] you know so your idea
there when you first start talking about
that that barrier so if if the if the
brain is more of like a like a r
receiver like a r rather than a
transmitter there we go so like maybe
that is the ultimate thing that that
we're going to learn is that we that it
is more of a receiver and there are
certain things that can erode that
barrier that make it hard to function in
like normal reality but there are ways
in which you can permeate that and have
those experiences if they're necessary I
don't know I like this like I don't know
this reality is pretty great you know
what I mean it's like I don't know I
don't know man do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is sto's butt
wipes for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get sto's hot sauce for
your butthole plus sto's butthole
destroyer and steo butt wipes for your
butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right
now yeah dude